what the digital start-up scene
is today, that was the creative
and advertising scene 20 30 years ago and there was a
star there who is more divorced to this
day than everyone else and his name is
jean remy from matt is the founder of
young from matt and puts in  absurd
life to this day it's now 70 but
a legend has built a house in
berlin and the chimney cupolas are
shaped after his wife's breasts he appears in
alina bernburg's book because of the house
mind you a lot of
crazy things most of the big
german campaigns last  decades
goes back to his creative input
so listen to the conversation with jo
remy von matt
is it actually was that your father
bible seller
so to speak but catholic
bookseller book and art dealer whereby
art that was not art as
we think and know it but that was
more like devotional
items, they were kind of crib crosses and you're there,
let's say that  had
a shop he had the bookshops exactly
book and art shop ok his own and
there and that was very religious and there it
was he played as far as catholicism
is concerned he already plays a role when he
was then also somehow
agreed in the catholic bookseller president in the
three countries  in German-speaking
countries and so he was
somehow just before a pastor you can say
okay okay and how did it finally start
you did get out of this bubble in your
switzerland invest the
hamburg way well i am so you can
almost say i was a kind of
economic refugee  because i came
out of advertising college in 73 and really
wanted to have a job in an
advertising agency
and at that time there was the oil crisis and there were
practically no jobs in an
advertising agency and i
applied everywhere in the whole
german-speaking area which happened to be around
the düsseldorf agency  the fastest
and so i ended up in
germany and have n  I regretted it
and then it was easier for me too. I
changed agencies from Düsseldorf
, went to Frankfurt, a large
agency in the
American network, then went to
Munich, got a creative main job, then I went
to hamburg and jacobi, and finally I started my
own business and I was
that we were springer & jacoby the particularly
the time i think i was the most
trend before self-
employment yes well that at springer jacoby you
actually learned how to set up my agency
so if you were
really thrown in at the deep end and
your own unit
that means it was actually the
perfect school
how i found my own agency has
shaped me so creatively
i have the time before that
i was in this munich agency for eight years this
is a and rimmel no
longer exists today  then just opened up here
and
shaped business or that's exactly
what boss christmann vert did for you  rubbed and
he's still manfred
rehm i'm still in contact with him and that was
so
practical he was then the mastermind of this
agency and for me also the number
one teacher and why did she then go away
well she somehow
said i was there for eight years
worked for four years it went
uphill ferries it went downhill and
i learned the most during the time
downhill from the mistakes that were
made there and at some point it
went downhill to such an extent that i thought
now i knew it had to change
and it's you with it
pulled along with us in the negativity
strobl helping the group we
started some well-known advertisers when
i mean you met
holger but there are i think i have a
whole handful of almost all the bigger
agencies that exist these
days like and then more or less there
kicked off
yes yes but so springer jacoby was
already a a cadre factory for for
many talents for many who then ebe  n
founded it ourselves but just as well there
was also scholz & friends at the
time so they were around a similar
time and there are many there
too many were born from this agency
who then founded etc and
how about it so you met holger
so off you go  made it personal right away or
was it just that
we worked now that it works
we will actually get to know each other through
a common ex-wife
and that was when I was at a
divorce date she had him there for
moral
support and then we met  got to know
each other and the first few years we never had much to do with each other because we were
had different hobbies and
so how personally we
didn't get closer at all in the first few years
but our appetite came with eating
so the longer we did it
the more we became friends, that
means we can actually only go to the
last  for the last ten years
claim that we have become friends
but
until then it was a good working of
reason and and a perfect
partnership and so also before the
foundation because the animal more or less
merkel we can work well together
and that's why we can together nee that
was  actually full risk because we
were we worked in the same
agency but in very different
places, i.e. i
had practically nothing to do with you directly i knew
him
through these private things we knew that
we had common interests we were
driving with the same woman
and the word a full risk that
you can't do that you can't
plan that you don't have up to worth either and
this risk was
successful so that means it was
lucky in the end that we
worked together perfectly but it could
have gone wrong and whatnot  back
then it was the division so it
was founded because people say okay now ka  nn
it's good enough now i'll do it myself
there were role models here or was
it just the desire to earn more money
or be more
independent from most companies
that like
what holger has to do had to ask
holger what doesn't do is it's the way i had it
I'm a very typical entrepreneur,
namely not one at all, so I've never dreamed of having my
own
company or
fighting back the entrepreneurs or something like that, it was
n't an issue for me at all, but I dreamed
of working for an agency in an
agency that  there weren’t any at the time
so that means i had some ideas
for an agency and i wanted to
work there and in
order for this to exist somewhere i
have to found a company somehow that means i
actually reluctantly became an
entrepreneur just to be able to work in an
agency that is after my
taste or built according to my
ideas that a culture has according to
my ideas and so and that  was
my drive it wasn't about money it was
n't just i come to me it's not at all i
didn't really
calculate what you can earn with your own
agency there was also the fact that
at springer & jacoby we made very good
money that's true but  there was no
suffering and so and i had that
was his pain from me that i said
man that is so little that should be
more and in fact in the first
years of the agency since we we have
for the first three years we  we were given
an
assistant so
we lived very modestly and very
diligently and always diligently
reinvested profits, that means the first
five to ten years were
not very lucrative for us and i had
practically earned more
as an employee than afterwards as an entrepreneur afterwards where
of course it was different at some point when
the company then had a plant and it
became clearer and bigger what were the
things you did with yours
wanted to have your own agency so what did you say because it mostly motivates you that was a
long time ago so 30 years
ago
the agency we were last in was
really very good it was very
well known and it worked a lot
and that was
just fine  the idea of the perfect school but i
was
always thinking ahead even back then so wh
t needs to be im
roved and what could be impro
ed i am basically a person who i
always thinking about improvement and deter
oration makes me sick so basic
lly i think about
every day where could i be  what should be
improved also what
concerns private things or should i
always want to improve
and a few things came to my mind so yes,
for example in dealing with people i.e.
with employees and so
on what could be improved
i can now i can’t
remember exactly  remember what it was all
but i know but i had i had
a vision of my own culture u
And then we really
implemented it and I'm really proud
that our founding was never understood as a
copy of our former
company, no one said
that's springer & jacoby
next level or or in a new one or him
differently or something but our founding
was from the beginning the agency was
experienced as something new something different and
there are a few elements created in
connection with the agency that
other companies or attachments tours so
don't have for example this
trojan horse old logo of the
trojan horse is something like that too
element do you have your own logo
your own
imagery wanted to have your own visual language for the agency
exactly but that the trojan horse
that unfortunately arose later
, so it's not one of the
things that we brought into the
agency from the start but that
's funny and  it didn't come
from me either, so many many ideas because I
just why the ideas person when from u  ns
two
ideas can often not come from me or the
trojan horse, for example
, that holger had it so
spontaneously in a customer presentation 1 he
said you have to imagine it
like the trojan horse and i sat
next to it and heard that and said
man that  isn't that we can
use that and since you have a picture and so on and you're
still very happy with it today, of course,
we thought about it, especially in the course of the media revolution, does this picture
still fit, so today it's still a good
idea like the trojan  horse
but it has been confirmed that he is
actually more concerned than ever and the
trojan horse that was well received everywhere
except in switzerland i
know that he is pacifist so
they always
experienced it as so martial and that's what they are
people  died and so on
because of this idea, that can't be anything
good, but in the meantime they're
proud to use it
and other things  I was also
standing at this agency thinking about a color
and allegedly you thought about the color for an
extremely long time, like the green, so
we’re talking about his British racing
green,
which is related to you, that
the euro is still expensive everywhere
, so to speak, in part  colored or
your whole appearance was also so professional, that's
how it should be, that's what I wish for.
Branding has always been an important
topic in this agency, so we placed
a lot of value on branding, on
branding elements, on our own
brand a bit too  according to the
motto if you don't maintain your own brand
, you shouldn't
trust anyone else either, that we said we have to
because you have to do this schoolwork
perfectly with us, otherwise we are
not credible
as advertisers who help
develop and maintain the brands and we
before the founding we got
together to see at all because
we didn't know each other that well to
see if we  having the same agency in
mind we withdrew
from the weekend
we drove to beet places that
just didn’t work out because of traffic jams and
always driving to fehmarn locked us
on the farm
and we answered 40 questions
independently of each other they
said next  tomorrow at breakfast
we'll put it together and then
we'll see if we're the same agency main
and they were driving back and
forth to the company color what could that be
the company color and then I
think there was no one to
say if I  one after
the other one has dark blue ones I think the other one is green
or something like that then again then
incredulous is made green out of it but
such topics as the fab like
this dark green there had to be a
door here in the house that had to be
painted four times until I  was
highly satisfied with this green and
another another detail you will
not find a photo so in 30 j  ahren there
is no photo where holger and i
are standing the wrong way around, but we are always standing so
that you can read young about matt that
means always more on the side and i
understand i have the left/right
weakness so it fits there are
no pictures that  would be because we always
changed sides as soon as someone had a camera in their hands or somehow we immediately switched sides
so we simply paid close attention to the
brand is always is is because at the
beginning there was perhaps another job
that we fell to the
front brought to the front  I'm particularly
proud and we're particularly important such
a creative but
a work from the early days that
I'm not proud of that's really
terrible
that was one of our first
customers again, the German city advertising
and they wanted to do a poster campaign
to attract smaller companies too
to say that poster advertising is valuable for you
and our idea was
somehow to depict such small animals
so hamster chicks and so on and the
dealers were somehow posters are not
just for big animals or
something like that and that was creatively modest at the time
and we then
asked the customer afterwards yes how
about the posters, they are
selling like hot cakes  found and so and the customer
said tanja a
penal institution has contacted us
and put up the two posters
nobody else so that was
our first first failure
in terms of successes i can no
longer remember the rest was okay the first
big customers were already direct  6 and
sonne sex was there sixt i had
already brought to the jumping kobe
i had taken care of in munich up to brought the
appropriate suit
and they then followed us
back but
also very exciting
after half a year they were gone
so after half a year  year
somehow recognized himself, man, this new
agency, they may be good, but they
care  not really about us
but they are so afterwards
to win new business in all places
and 6 was disappointed and took the
budget away from us again after that
luckily we stuck with it
and after another year we had
the budget again and until today
and  now i have been
working for this company for 35 years i have never had
this close personal
relationship with her
but recently it
came about so three years
ago erich offered me six what for
me that is for me the best prize
the most beautiful award  who i was able to
win for the work on this stamp
because that was a
sublime moment that was funny about
that flew over cyprus in his chat
after together to israel and over cyprus he toasted
a glass of champagne in his hand
since then it's erich and that
was that was a very nice
award for me so for but made the
multitude i mean the 30 years
previously done a lot of advertising so they
exchanged but that was that was
a very sober
relationship so very factual because that
is if you will the x6 is my
second teacher or or a very
important influence for me I learned a
lot from
von erich sixt and  also that it's about
the thing and not about the people
sitting there at the table, but it's
always about the thing and so we
worked together, so
we never had any kind of personal
exchange or how are you or
then you drive  on vacation or something
but you sat down and
then it was about the thing and that's also
a situation like that all these
crazy motives came about that we
've all known for 20 30 years exactly
exactly in such a situation arises so
exactly so actually completely  different from what
you think you think somehow that
's so creative and there are a lot of
people on the phone at the bildraum
but in the distance is e  s very sober that
was that was always the meetings were
always very sober and also demanding
so these were often very long meetings
and the special thing was
that that is ultimately the reason
for the quality of this campaign that
i care about them very personally  took
care of the matter and very personally
approved things or or was also willing to take risks
and
also had an influence yes
which of the six motives is
best remembered so which
of all was better to
do with ms merkel and the  stormy hairstyle or that we
were on it ourselves so Mrs. merkel with
the stormy hairstyle is of course the
best known and that's really
interesting that was a long time ago i do
n't know 12 years or or longer
but it's still being quoted
today and it's still an
issue today  this motive and the nice
thing was that mrs merkel reacted very easily to it at the time
when she didn't
somehow have a  lawyers tried but
on the contrary she was then asked in a
television interview
what she thinks about the motive and she said
yes the motive if she is actually good only
with the photo his mistake happened because
that would not
show her driving a convertible but when looking at
it  the tax plans of the
opposition
and she really took that
with her and also developed it herself in the
story about the
motif we ourselves can do so where we
are depicted as beggars also a very nice
anecdote the motif
came about as follows
six although always a beaming customer
of  but never a very
lucrative one from us but that was just so
it was he we just did it out of
passion and because it was our founding
customer but unfortunately it was
never very
lucrative and at some point the our
financial was told me man  it ca
n't go on like this and we put
it on top of that with the customers and you have to
change that and you are  t the only one he's on the line has an
issue with the customer and please
set the following prices
otherwise we'll have to give up the customer
I thought oh god
that's probably not going to work because I
knew
erich 6 and his negotiating skills and stuff
and I don't have
any at all  and i flew under it
with these with this price list and
already on the plane i thought oh god i
need a plan b so i wo
n't be able to enforce the prices and
then i had the idea for a plan b i painted
something on the plane and a motif
holger points to me as a
beggar with the flip side so that we can
continue to rent mercedes cheaply
we pushed our agency down the price
and i then went to him
and after five minutes my
price list was shredded with a few
arguments and navi is per 6 then there
there is only one chance that we
remain partners you have to place this motif in all
major newspapers and at major
airports  n then we can continue
to be together, otherwise it wo
n't work anymore and six looks at the
motif and says yes, do it
and then this motif appeared in all the
major daily newspapers because
it was still an important medium back
then and then it was a  for a year at
hamburg airport at munich
airport to see very strikingly and
with that
it was amazing because that was a great motif for 6 it
was also an interesting
personal pr experience for us as an agency
you are a rather
withdrawn introverted type that was
that  uncomfortable that you tell me at
hamburg airport where he also, so to speak,
the whole peer group business people cross country
every day,
so to speak, that they then see you every day, so to speak, and he is a
bit so exposed
i just look like an introvert
i'm not in trouble so that's
just it  a mixture of
that you don't on the contrary i thought
that i was a cool idea
is many an
inte  Interesting picture,
no, no, I had nothing against that at all and that
really led to the fact
that some of the
cameras on the plane said, man, everything you do
for six is so great and that’s why I
reserved a seat for you in business class
or so
ething like that  i was
upgraded and so on so this kind
of notoriety
was never a bad thing that happened several times
you can also
be seen in motives yourself it was there that you the
second thing to me is the head problem above all
that with the
underwear
yes  that was exactly that, too, that was also
a bit of a bet, because it was a
campaign that i presented in may
and there were of course certain
hesitations, does it work
with people, so people are really
willing to show
themselves in underwear for little
money  and then
I said okay if you do the campaign,
I promise you
that I'll do it too, then I'll do it and
then  n it just ran and then I
already when I then when it became
concrete I already have to train a bit
I didn’t have it so
afterwards it said I had the picture we
hadn’t edited the picture that
but the picture was practically before the
I worked on the shooting as an
expert I did
n't work, not the retouching,
I worked and of
course that was quickly known
and so on and went around but god these
are also
stories that you make but it shows
also that i can't be that introverted
and i had also once
made a motif for for younger readers so suits for suits
exactly and it was that was shortly after
a divorce the motif
shows tears with tears in the eyes
nice suit and somehow our
suits last longer than the
average marriage and something
the police that was like i said both
it was that that
advertising was its wild time back then,
to say that yours also suffered a bit
from the job in the whole
industry because you value yourself
a bit before the party and as a
celebrated creative person you have the choice
of women it was a bit like
i do think that the
failure of the marriage had something to do with the job
, but in a different
way, it was just
a lot of work and i warn i
wasn't
just in my own right from the start  company but i
was very focused on the job
i really worked a lot
and put a lot of passion into the
ideas put into the campaign
and so of course it's
not necessarily
suitable for a partnership
right or don't you have one of these
famous ones  claims most of them made up themselves
so there are a few stingy
is cool or form your opinion
so things for which now stands di  e
outlast the time, so to speak, in the
end i want to come from you personally
so the many ideas or many distinctive
ideas of the first ten years or the
first ten 15 years are already mine
but it is not always but i was
not always the creator but
sometimes was  I also the one who somehow
looked through a list and
said man spirit is awesome that
that's it that we have to
make something out of it or something like that who discovered a talent, so to speak
, in a
formulation not all of me and
at some point I became constantly for
praised things that I had nothing to do with anymore
and had a really bad
conscience so then it was man, because
here the creative ones are that the
bdk did this and that and then
I always thought oh god that wasn't me
at all  that was but then i
consoled myself with the fact that ultimately
i created a culture in which something
that was possible even became
probable and so of course i did  I
also made a contribution to the Danes that took place in
the last ten years.
From your point of view, what is the difference between
this poster sale because you said
the animals were such a small animal
on it? The posters are also
what big animals they are  it's
funny at first and you think like that as a claim
it works at first glance
similar to how it was now you have another good
saying like how stingy is cool but
how can you make
it clear to someone who doesn't feel it right away that it
's another  kind of quality is i
didn't feel it grams off
when i wrote that i
also thought that's a good idea and stuff
and then it just didn't look particularly good
and it wasn't particularly well received and so
i'm in my
job  First of all, very self-critical and
very feedback-oriented, which means that the
idea is never good for me if
I find it good, but only good
when I notice that something is happening  something
that
created momentum people think it's
great there's a demand or something like
my house my car my boat
that we give away that we to the host
vernacular of the world quotes or something like that
then I realize what has to happen that must have been a
good idea  it hit the
nerve but when i
write it down on paper i might have a
feeling or something or or in the hope
but the proof is always only at the end
my house my car my boat that has
also become completely popular
when did you  then felt it is so
broad i think today
more people say it than ever can
trace it back to where it
comes from ebay
ebay 3 2 1 that was exactly the savings bank
and the knowledge i'm angry too i
know the saying you make it  fun but you
know exactly today you always know but we knew for a long time
and
the interesting thing about the saying
is that many of my ideas came
from everyday life so the w  ar were
somehow experienced situations that i
then
processed in commercials or
whatever and my house my car my
boat that was a very concrete
experience i at a class reunion
and i
just had i had not created anything for a long time
i had little money for a relatively long time and
all my classmates who had
already married had children who
had all sorts of things and i was
confronted with
lots of people leafing through photos on the table my house
my car my boat my house my car
i always felt like living around because i
had no photos and nothing  and back then there
were no mobile phones and that's how
this film came about and there were
several situations from everyday life that I was able to process in
films or in ideas
reference to a regular part after
your podcast, namely aleikum
die ko aleikum is a young
company  this tries to
close the gap between what e-commerce
shops and retailers do  be able to afford
and what buyers often expect
it is often about having the right feel
services for the customer proactive
shipping communication track and trace
a digital tour portal at marie all of
this is what customers simply expect many companies
can’t do it like that then
it’s aleikum  overall,
they ensure that your fulfillment as a
retailer is much, much easier if
you hand it over to a co. you can
escalate infinitely. it is a very
simple control of the al-ko
platform  for his grand prix just
like many others the chicks film
including chocolate no wonder that
the ratings of rajko users at mr reviews are
well above the
industry average so the stars of these
are obviously significantly higher if
you want to know more everywhere aiko all the
info on  the landing page co.com
mr
we only go w then  Any
political communication going on with you
I also have a lot if I know
worked for Mrs. Merkel worked for other
politicians
was that something special for you or
describes it exactly you had at the
beginning what he had in the
very first founding meeting
we also thought about that we work a
lot of water we don't work and even
then we decided
politics that you never go out for politics
there were reasons the first of the
one-offs the reason was they
always know everything better and we can
never get our way there  then there was also a reason
it's a very discontinuous
business there's no one to choose from and
then afterwards people have to
get rid of them again and so somehow and
unnaturally each party means a
coloring for the agency so if you
put it very roughly if it's with
the ones with the black tribes are
mad at the employees when it comes to the red
tribes, the customers suck  r and so
somehow just that bothers
independence and independence was
always a
big topic for us and now a
few years ago there was a request from
ms merkel and that was very
personal so it wasn’t
just that the committee wanted it in some way,
it was  Mrs. Merkel personally
was of the opinion that Matt Soldiers
should make representations and it
was also a situation like that. It was a situation
where the Afg reached 20 percent for the first time in Meck-Pomm,
I think,
and that was also about
democracy and  around the middle and so and there
I went against the opinion of all the other
board members so everyone was against it
said no don't do that that's
nonsense and we shouldn't do that and
then I said then he is I
definitely want to do it so it was more  or
less going it alone and how was
aware that it
wouldn't be that it wouldn't be a big campaign
because Mrs. Merkel is that's her
success she is she's conservative
n  of course she is he
[music]
so she she isn't brave she does
n't take any risks and so everything
everything that distinguishes her
was of course for
fascinating idea not
plastic and that's exactly how it was when that
means the work was then relatively
well-behaved so  nothing that you
proudly pin on your lapel but for me
personally it was a year for you can
you accompany him so every week
to have a jour fixe in a small circle with
this fascinating woman to put together
your thoughts your worries your needs and so on  continuing
to experience it live and somehow being able
to talk to it that was very
enriching, so for me it was a
cool time
and that was a bit in the
twilight of my career, so that means
it was sort of my last, my
last act or my last  year
as an operational creative who was also
on the front line and
i want to time i don't want to measure the time
the woman is still great and great
d  so u haven't been that
long ago even though we run
one of the biggest german digital film
today worked in the early
phase zalando took part how can that
actually
be caused by oliver samba so
there was only one relationship i had
always visited  in berlin and we are
kind of
friends and that's how
this collaboration came about and that
was really interesting because at that time
salander was really just a small
plant and
with our campaign it was
already a day on
well nationally known popular
before popular brand  with this
campaign scream before happiness which was
originally called scream before happiness or
six back but fate can
then be cashed in or did
samba and his brother alexander summer
cash in because
too many used it
and and then it was called writer luck
but it was one  interesting time and
a great campaign robert gentz was of
course also quite  at the forefront and
who is one of the decision-
makers of the founders are you still top hat and
dry or later have character or
what was unique, so to speak, the work
together well that was it was a
collaboration that lasted five years
and afterwards there were always
contacts with the means  its something of
course but also with zalando from
edit currently again for
zalando we are doing a campaign in
berlin for them i heard that means
that if you do some
research you get along
very well with various billionaires so at
16 mr dommermuth will be  with the seeds what
so there is a certain closeness because they
are also so keen on perfection or
are just as annoyed as you say it
is just a coincidence it was clear
that my wife
noticed
that we are always the poorest in our circle of friends
are
the only ones who come on foot or
by public transport
i can't do it so these are people  e
who I admire and who I admire for
things that are completely foreign
to me, i.e. the entrepreneurial and and such and maybe they will get along well with me because I
tick completely
differently and
think completely differently but I also noticed
that  most of my friends are
able to do that in which
the
time or the
flow of creativity generates
so it really stops what
our the shower a there is this
famous thinks thinks bright so it's
really that I have to sit somewhere
alone in a  quiet space is then
already an artwork technique that you have
acquired so my experience is
that every creative person is very
different and
quite concretely there are creative people who
are creative when they are surrounded by as
much inspiration as possible it corresponds
to other people or music  listen
or or or sit in a nice
place somewhere and see something nice
or in the film and  for me it's exactly the
opposite so i'm most creative
when i don't see at all when there's no one in the
room when i
just listen to myself in maine in
my memory and then something occurs to me
and yes,
ideas come to me, well, everything  everything that distracts
is bad, which means you have
also created an environment here
where others can get their creativity out in a completely different
way, exactly we have, we
always have
something that was always very important to us too
, was such a liberal culture,
so that everyone is free to do
their own thing  to develop ideas in the way that
suits him best, i.e. only
results count, we have
always told people if you can get the ideas
out there, at home
or in the pub, then do it
there, so nobody needs to be here
its to develop ideas and in
the end change so in the end it was
always about the results and that's what gave
us this fixation on ideas and
results  e and on the product itself
on the creative product itself has
always given us a bit of a reputation, a
negative reputation and being
human because in fact when
we had a meeting
like that I was never really
interested because everything is in place now
what's their name where do they come from what
the glamorous state of mind
good but i was always interested in what
they have with them but
what's on the list and what can
we work on so i was always very
focused on
the thing itself on the idea on
the creative  product and well if
you want you can
call it inhuman i don’t call it inhuman but i
wasn’t like that
i don’t know so
feel empathetic towards the meeting and control it but it was
more about the thing was there ever
another name for  the agency that was up for
debate except
yes so the first name it was an idea
of mine catas
rophe i had i wanted the agenc
young and power call i thought it
was funny
happy and and holger had a
trauma he said he followed me in
creative things how often and
said yes why not he had a
nightmare so somehow it said
on a big sign and everyone
laughed
and he had told me this dream
and then i'm so glad i did
that that we didn't do that [ __ ]
but somehow i found it
weird or funny or i thought
somehow that will be
known quicker i don't know that was the
only alternative
that
yes exactly that was the only
after after a certain at the beginning
it is yes at the beginning is through was quite
clever if you named a company after
you because
it speeds up the start because
somehow your name stands for
a certain quality we were both
with  our name we were already
profiled in the industry and that means
it's quite good for the tractor driver but
then i wanted something  ndwann quickly
and from today's point of view today I would
prefer it to be called something else but
something anonymous it comes to the fact that
today's agencies are
not called differently like law firms
like in the past but today's anton is
called media monks or twelve ponies or
whatever  so any
fantasies about
that means there's a bit of a
company called jung von matt that
's practically self-disclosure we
're from the 90s
and renaming it would also be nonsense or
yes that would be nonsense because the brand
is very well known  the worst thing I
kept encountering was that and to shorten it
to kvm so I always wanted that that
was and it didn't catch on
that was rejected again and again
but I still think it's
a good idea I had to be more
institutional beforehand it will be
connected with us and  it is so we want to come with
you jvm point even called as an appointment
is a secret number exactly we
have  en
da i'm very happy that we have
com/de there we have at
we have ch ch was quite funny because
my brother that my brother's company
in format in switzerland and i
said you need jvm ch and he says you
i looked  but the website belongs to
the domain belongs to a
cycling group that organizes a race for a
deceased friend
the hoe vogeli every year
is called shock for birds the
memorial
and that has to be solved that can you have to
come to the website and so and a
month later he called  me as apple
just good news and bad
news
the good news is we now have
the domain i have a point before ch
because the bad news is we
are the
main sponsor of the chess promotion lines for the next ten years
and sent me a photo why seniors
cyclists wise 60 70-year-old
cyclists drove around with our logo but reached their destination
okay if you hear it all like that now
my feeling is sozus  agen der
peter whom he also got, so to speak,
yes, to continue running the agency, that
’s a completely different type than
you, you don’t want to say that i
mean what was that, the logic was to
get peter, fortunately he’s different
because when  he as much as us who coaches the
company probably now
because i am convinced that
other talents require a different talent
constellation to found a company
and bring it to a certain level in
order to further
develop and lead it
and i mean that holger  and me we
were ideal for the first ten years
and okay for the second ten years but
definitely suboptimal for the next ten
years that means it was very important that
someone with different skills came in
and developed the company
further i'm pretty
sure we would have  which has now been run for the last ten
years
, somehow it's
about
it  wraps what you can say is
a few was because at least from an
economic point of view it is accurate
it has become wider that has become larger
it
has also become more complex and
so new
new things have developed
and since I
am unsatisfied mister we remain  I think
human it can go even further
so there is still room for improvement
that can be seen but all of
us we all see that the brand is
strong like is very well known and
you can make something out of it
you are at
home, so to speak  with all of
today’s media channels or kukksi
at least do you want your personal
relationship with which we have a lot of
communication today so
no longer facebook but also as
instagram and so on
i’m not really secretly but
naturally
interested and have
read everything  and follows everything whenever there is
something new then I read it
through and such but I am also
convinced d  apart from the fact that if you don't
really use it and don't live it yourself
and right now, for example social
media, you can't read about
it, you have to experience it, so you have to have experienced
all the effects live to
really understand it  to be able to
and that's not me, I didn't
notice that on social media, for example, a few
on the platforms, some with
my names, some with something else and so
look around a bit but I ca
n't say about myself that I have a
company there and that's why I had  I also
get out because I think a
very important point in order to be
successful is firstly to be
aware of what I can do and
secondly to be aware of what
I can't do and what I prefer to govern
or what I prefer to look for a partner for
and that was for me  always very important
and there's a hell of a lot
that I can't do or where I can't
where I'd rather not guess now,
for example th  things like
asking about taste that you give him a
so design that was never
my skin but because I always
depended on other opinions
and I then got them or even
economic issues no idea
about it so I’m not an
entrepreneur in that sense but
I had  partner but you, say, for example
, made a saying very early on via social media that
has traveled extremely
far and to this day
all of a sudden even a completely different perception or completely different
correctness than before i mean saying
with the curves the internet exactly the
saying  is actually more up to date
than ever was that was an
internal mail back then that was also a bit
unfavorable so a quickly written
internal mail and very emotional
mail to all employees where I was
furious at any
criticism of a campaign by von  us
they weren't just from the sea from someone
else but i was annoyed
and dan  n i somehow wrote
blogs are the rough end of the internet
was he blogs or the campaign
torn up first mistake so
no mistake on my part the flour became of
course you can't
send confidential mail to 800 employees but very logically that
someone is the one and second
I wasn't precise, but what
I meant were the comments, the
comment columns in blogs and forums, and
I really meant that there were
many people posting hate and hate speech out of
anonymity for the best and somehow
quasi
anonymously, and
I found that back then
somehow
shot from an ambush and
i still stand by the opinion that that's the groovy thing about
the internet and
the crazy thing is that this well i
've been trying for 50 years to
come up with distinctive formulations i.e.
formulations that are somehow exciting
are they hitting the nerve and so
to put it bluntly, i have an egg
I managed the new york times a little bit like that walls
of the internet because in the new york times
bring and otherwise i never
made it
[laughter]
it means you already
anticipated a bit what you see today
hate speech about the whole thing exactly it is
it hits exactly what is being
discussed today highspeed and i had
already gotten applause from some people when i quoted that
, especially from top journalists like the
south german newspaper faz or something like that
you said you are right and that also
went on the  annoying this kind of
expressions of
opinions from the ambush and stuff
but of course i was put down on the net
first and so on
that often cost it almost a bit
image back then because you
didn't understand why it meant the internet
it's really me too  yes in the
national or perception damaged
maybe that's true that's true but
it also caused damage because clearly like
the e  ben that's often the case that
was then simplified
and then made of it at some point
the internet doesn't want it or doesn't want it
no internet wants to
undo it or something like that I've always
argued against it but that does
n't help anymore either  i said
people with the things you deal with the
most that cause the most suffering, with
whom you are most critical, that
means of course we are interested in the
internet, but we do
n't catch everything that way, or i
personally found it very interesting  in my opinion i
didn't find everything glorious what the
internet has given us and
was essentially this one
point of criticism of
new partners here in the podcast
kyoto-2
from the end redirected the scan that one
and loading is indycar document cloud
up and then it comes  big advantage
and can distribute the mail to companies much better to see
exactly who
needs to get what  en we have to
sign the forms have to be
filled out the bill has been
due all this of course makes life a
lot more efficient
and kaya helps with that or that
would like to rest I would also like to benefit from this increase in
efficiency
try it out and above all use the
discount code the first five  months kaya
with 50 discount if you just go to
money cards and there with the
voucher code mr 1 there is daily updated
post paperless set up in five minutes
you sometimes look
at rating portals there are also employer
rating portals and agencies in particular
do not have an easy position per se
because of course
general agencies also have a lot of fluctuation
, as I need it too, as if
you read it then there are quite a lot of
people who complain very specifically about their
jobs here. kukksi is of
course a relevant one, you say that’s
what the operational colleagues do now
me always very late a  evenings
to walk in very late in the evening
i watch then we watch something
and then i read and so but also
so
the whole thing is interesting a woman is
always there so if there is something stupid next to it is
about me or or something because i
look very upset and  says man
that's impudent and so
on but there I am of course
put through three decades
so practically in
the public eye I want to
get a
magazine article on the
way with which rightly also traveled far
is different again and that when I
tell  we people we do here in
the films about young von matt and want to
tell the impact what
i said yes you have to address the dates
he lives in berlin in the apartment
and there are somehow the the roof or
the roof of the chimney is after
shaped his wife's breasts that's so that's
i think everyone who knows you has
it in their heads that they did it consciously
or because that  just coincidence or how
certain people get to choose mainly chimney ceiling
so it shows, of course, so you
don't do something like that to remain anonymous, of course you don't
do something like that
for yourself and don't show anyone, but of
course there is a pleasure in
provoking pleasure  the idea
was that it was also a bit of a
crazy idea because i was sitting there with the
architect and i said hey
, google has that, i always
kind of look at cities and they
all look incredibly boring selection
roofs are always the same  and why
don't we build the craziest roof in
the world with a capsule of ideas and
ideas and i'm all boring
and stuff and then at some point
i thought man that could be an
art and why not the most beautiful
breast in the world etc and well me  I
think at first I listened silently and he thought
I had gone crazy, but
then we did that, then I thought, then
I have my wife  asked if she
would have anything against my wife my wife
is very open so she said to me she
gets on really well with my players
if you do the jail there
i don't think it's cool but you
don't mind either and yes and then have
I thought to myself, if I am myself, I
have often accused our customers of not having the
courage for
a spectacular idea, then I ca
n't be pinched myself now,
I'll just do it
and see what will come of it and
see it that way  I'm happy with
stories like that and as far as this apartment is concerned,
the apartment despite now being a bit
full of ideas and
madness  let off steam the
only thing i didn't like is that they
now understood it as luxury like
a luxury penthouse or something like that because
i was never that luxury  topic but the topic
was always
unusual shapes unusual
ideas and so on
well well i'm actually quite satisfied with the
apartment because
he always visits us or so
at least finds it exciting or to
do says nothing bad equal
finds a few is  yes very domestic use it
says on the outside this house used to stand
on top of each other exactly that is also that
is also one of those things would also be that has
a little history we
bought this house and how it is after the
signature at the notary you
then go back to the  street
kukksi the house my wife looks at the house and says
man bought the ugliest house on the
whole street or was it a
bit depressed and then I spontaneously
said from then on I promise you it
will be the most photographed one
and then I have for
months  i think about what can
you write on your facade so that it
gets special value that
people notice it  n the photographing
that is now not just a painting
and has a meaning so just content
food for thought and then I came up with this
sentence this protest used to be in
another country and above it is
human waves can move anything
and
the result was actually that is the
most photographed house  there are
postcards of it there are posters of it
there are fridge magnets of it and
constantly when you look out of
the window we constantly see people taking the photo
or four stretching berlin spree mobile phone
that's on tour
strasse schulstrasse and what's really interesting
with  the sentence
the young understanding gang they
watch say why in another country
and so the 20-year-olds check the
sentence no longer even know
what that means because it's already
over and forgotten but because that became
the media report on density
saying that and who
said this I think that's where
my s originally appeared was what worked the most  üddeutsche zeitung i
don't think that the first
portrait about the apartment or about the
house
in the faz was something boccherini
and then in his apartment
everyone and then the roof story the tabloid press
just
concluded that it was us everywhere
got a woman angry
because that didn't make her but
said people all day we
started people
on their breasts
doesn't need him and you ca
n't prevent it like that and so i apologized
but it was over after a day like
that  is the best in the end so if
i hear it like that now there are
photos i never got the hang of it but it
seems as if you have a
flair for architecture don't say
it was a bit of a matter of
luck because normally when you do something
know about show
effects so basically if you
design a room as if it were a small
museum with different ideas, in the
end it's no more  cozy and then
it's a museum but somehow you
no longer know where to sit down
or feel good and
somehow we were lucky because it's a
nice, comfortable room where you feel where you are, even
as a couple when we like to live there
with us  with guests there
we can have nice dinners with 30
people and so i think i'm that
with the room i'm very happy but
it's a bit of luck because i
never learned it and it could have
gone wrong but it's still a
drive  from the even more real estate
houses into easy things so
that space started and I've
always been interested in that case it
was a very nice collaboration
between my wife and me because my wife has
the taste, so to speak, and the
creativity for shapes and colors  and
materials brought in and I brought in
the ideas that worked out
wonderfully
together but I've
always had an f  aible for interior design we
have here so the most spectacular
room in the company is that the
most common living room in germany piles up
this living room that had that was an
idea that was ages ago so also 15 years
or so but it has an enormous
impact so it had a
press
coverage worth a million i think it
was all the television stations wanted to film there
one even wanted to do a talk show
there so this germany's
frequent is living room was a great
idea
or 3d idea from us of yes
exactly but that means customers want to watch
then too  and in the end it was
so that you
better think of your target group, that became
a real place of pilgrimage for
marketing, so all the customers of large
companies came
to experience normality and that was
a room in which nothing happened,
but everything
everything was market research everything was
calculation so the the the the floor covering
the color the up  aser wallpaper follows 52
coarse-grained etc. it was all the
dimensions like the height of the room
everything was statistics and then there are
things that you
can't record statistically why
cover things and for that we visited ten
families who exactly
meet and have the average criteria
took photos there what they
exhibit then it was just a
michael schumacher keeps everything possible
and what books are there so the
brecht write encyclopedia and
and we copied everything so it
was really a perfect average and
gerhard schröder found it so exciting
me  told him that once and he
found it so exciting was
going to visit the room where you came from here in
the karolinenviertel again with
security and all sorts of things and
he was in the room for an hour and
looked at everything but it will
be like that again  makes another career
as someone who doesn't design houses
or design spaces than  oh that
's out of the question if the brand were
there and now, so to speak, with the success of
the first projects
that it won't happen because
I'm already at the age where I
no longer
feel like doing it, but now my things that
I myself
where I  I'm the master of my own ideas
so we're fortunately able to do it now
and now
to take on the order
the biggest defeat for you of all years
he had so of course there is
first of all netherlands there are of course
many from the beginning even in the phases
of our greatest successes or so
there were always defeats
that you were shaken up every day
and what i experienced very often  is
that somehow in the evening I was completely
shaken up by difficulties
, defeats, termination or  so you got
in the kink and can someone come up
to me and he says
congratulations and i thought
congratulations i spin off you experienced the biggest
[ __ ] in my career and
that's why the board
got oh so yes that's true
but
so  the industry so you have to have a
thick skin that it
is always positive, i.e. without
alcoholism, what
is pouring in but if you like the
biggest defeat or
rolling away the biggest test for our
agency or test was definitely
the loss of the mercedes budget because  that
was a huge budget, a lot was
done and there were more than 200
jobs and of course that was when you
heard again we are out there
that was at first a glimpse into
the abyss i thought [ __ ] that can
go wrong so if there is now
stupid coincidence wants
a few other things to
slip then it wasn't
meh  r
but even then, the
brand strength, i.e. the power of the brand
and also the culture of
the mountain railway, the strong culture
made itself felt because the team stays together,
so the most important people
stayed together, the most important customers
stayed and we
still have steps forward  done so
that two years later we had
an excellent result again, so
not only economically but above
all creatively and
the experience, i.e. this loss
of mercedes, was at the same time the greatest
defeat as well as, in retrospect, the
greatest success of the agency or the
greatest satisfaction because  to experience how
you got
back on your feet after the blow and how the
agency got going again and in
the end didn't lose any of its
momentum that was an experience for me
how we are indestructible so
if that didn't kill us then
we can  nothing more to come and
seen in this way it went against that in two
directions but of course what
first of all isn't a nice story
in advertising doesn't grow old so
it's a young industry yes of course
you can't you can't it
's so that of course at 60
or
65 I already asked myself do you want
become an ever worse applicant for the next ten years
or do you want to
start something new where you can't get any
worse because you start at the
bottom and it can only go straight ahead
in the worst case or get
better i don't think so i don't think
so of course  the
change has come
the colleagues from api mio
you know
market research companies are
no longer a start-up in which you are allowed to have a small
stake where the ceo
and founder of the jonathan chorfest was
in the podcast a few months ago so a
company is off  our babbel asked me
which one was so funny
currently very often higher let's say something like that
and it was clear straight away okay the central
and en fts brodsky in so subjects
regularly but it’s just my little
bubble on linkedin my feed on
instagram in my environment something like this
keeps popping up that helps the colleagues
from apple because they now
want to find out for themselves  how representative
is that really what you
perceive yourself and that's why 1000 people ask
and then just really representative to create
the so-called up in uk trade report
there are now the mails
for the most diverse areas for
session for food for automotive
and then  you can experience what is really relevant to
your neck in the respective areas
if you want to take a look
the first report goes live on march 16
you can already register for the download
at off to the
points
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr